- The fact that the artists
can continue to get royalties.
- To the revolution.
It's a revolution, Roger.
I mean like, my God.
(plane engine running)
Yeah!
- You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(keyboard music)
- Gary V, welcome to origin stories.
- Thank you, my friend.
Thank you so much for having me.
- This came together fast and
I could not be more thrilled.
We go way back.
I don't even know if you know this,
but we go back to, I think, '07.
How about that?
- Seems like yesterday.
I do know.
And it's crazy that it's
been that many years already.
- Insane.
And so now we find ourselves
years later intersecting
in the wonderful world of NFTs.
So tell the people, what
is your origin story.
- In the macro or in the world of NFT?
- Let's go blitz.
Let's go blitz style macro
just in case somebody doesn't know.
And then let's get deep
into the NFT space.
- You know, born in the Soviet union,
very fortunate to be able to be a refugee,
and get out late in the late seventies,
poor, poor kid, lived in
Queens and New Jersey,
Parents made their American dream.
Dad became a stock boy in a liquor store.
Eventually a manager, eventually
bought his own small store
which meant we saved every
penny, bought nothing.
You know, that created a--
With my natural entrepreneurial DNA,
and then my circumstance
and environment, created
incredible ambition
and scrappiness,
shoveling snow, washing cars
selling lemonade, you know, very
it was just always, always there.
Sports cards exploded
in late eighties became a
cultural phenomenon similar
to where it's at right now.
That's where I really learned my craft.
Doing baseball card shows
really became a seller,
buyer and seller.
Got dragged into my dad's liquor store,
cause now we had one.
Stocking shelves, two bucks an hour
you know, merchant son kind of
1940s, fifties style, right?
Like immigrant life.
Terrible student, really
good businessman as a kid.
Discovered the internet
in 95, two seconds in
and said, "Oh my God, that's
going gonna change my life."
Year later launched an e-commerce website
for my dad's wine shop.
One of the first in the country.
Took over operations,
and ran the business from '98 to 2011.
And in that 13 year window
built my dad's business
from a $3.8 million to a
$65 million dollar business.
No capital infusion, no
VC money, no credit line,
just fucking grinded it.
Innovated email, you know, NFT right now
is just deja vu.
You know, all the games,
the games being formulated
the winners and the losers.
There's some big differences,
but a lot of similarities.
Who were going to be the search engines?
Who were going to be the domain sites
where you registered your domain?
Who were going to be,
you know, and then really
culminated with YouTube.
I won on email
and Google ad boards,
but then YouTube changed my life.
I started a wine show.
I learned about content,
became completely obsessed
with the next revolution that
I saw, which was social media.
I've been talking about
NFT as the third revolution,
for me personally.
There's been a lot of
technology, what's that?
- Connected those dots, social media NFTs.
I've, I've been hearing
you say that recently.
- For me in my chemicals,
95, six
just kind of internet, consumer internet.
Obviously it was happening
before 2005, six social web 2.0.
before with Friendster.
Same with NFT now, right?
You know, one
of the reasons I posted
a video for me in 2010
talking about virtual goods is,
I've been watching, you know
I bought a Ethereum in '16.
I bought Bitcoin in '14.
I've been watching, but
I haven't been talking
because for me,
I'm not the person that is there
from day one and constantly there.
I am there from day one.
And that I watch.
And what I look for is
why I've been talking
since winter is the moment where I'm like
"Oh shit, it's time."
I mean, I'm spending a ton of time on VR.
I don't think I've said a
single public thing about VR.
And then in 2027, when it's
time, I'll be very loud.
The OGs will be like, "Hey, is this guy?"
And I'll be like, Hey,
OGs, I'm here to respect.
You know, I'm on this
podcast out of respect
to be honest with you.
I, I did it with web 2.0.
I did it with web 1.0, like I watch.
And then I enter.
I am definitely a consumer
human more than a technologist.
So that comes with great
excitement, but also caution.
And that's what I'm spending time on now.
Caution, empathy,
compassion, thoughtfulness.
I love this time.
The, you know, it's a little
different for me this time
because the last two times
I was much more unknown.
So I've got, I have to be more careful
more thoughtfulness this
time because unfortunately,
well, I'm flattered by this,
but unfortunately
when you want to be part
of a community, you know
you have to be your
your platform becomes your vulnerability.
You know, I come in, I
come in very respectful
to the people that have
been grinding and learning,
building the tech and the early artists.
And I'm not naive.
I know that my projects
and the things I care about
will have a lot of eyes on them
which if I'm thoughtful will be good.
And if I'm not thoughtful
ruins my reputation and upsets people.
And so
you know
I hope the community can tell
through my earliest actions
over the last six to seven weeks
that I'm trying to be very
thoughtful and I care about it.
This is like the culmination of my life.
I've never had a technology.
Social media was close.
I'm very human oriented.
I love people.
So social work for me
I want to interact with people,
like replying to comments.
It's not about post it and step away.
It's about post it and listen, engage.
I was, I come from very little
so I never think I'm fancy.
Like humility is an incredibly
important foundation
to my success.
It may not come across that way.
I know that I'm an aggressive
communicator, I'm loud.
I'm very excited, which
sometimes I think people confuse
for audacity, but I'm
compassionate and empathetic.
So I understand why.
So I'm willing to deal with
negative judgment upfront
because I know the truth wins, you know?
So it's a very fun time
but NFT, my God, you know,
the collectability aspect.
- Wait, before we get into
that, what I want to double down
on what you just said is the word respect,
and what I hope
that I personally can
add to this equation,
bringing you onto an origin story,
telling that origin story,
telling you know, why did
you enter the NFT space?
What I can add following you since '07.
You're allowed sometimes, right
in sometimes the best of ways.
But if someone catches you
at just the wrong moment
just that literal wrong moment
they can have a different impression.
What I personally want to
say is I've watched you
become obsessed with multiple things
over the course of over a decade.
And I can just say my stamp
for whatever that's worth
for anybody listening to this
you are a respectful person
and the empathy is outrageous.
And if you caught Gary at the wrong moment
for whatever reason, keep listening
and you will all come around in due time.
- That's made me emotional.
So thank you.
That's very, very nice of you.
To your point.
For example, this weekend, I'm like,
Oh shit, a lot of people
who are in for a quick buck are going
to run into this and buy some project
because somebody told
them it's going to go up.
And when I say, hey, 97% of NFT projects,
not the NFT space, are very vulnerable
to not being successful investments.
I believe that to be true out of history
out of knowing human psychology.
I also, you know
and so you can imagine
if somebody sees that
they're like, "Fuck this guy"
like you don't, you know,
and I'm like, I get that.
And I'm like, no, no, no.
If you look at, to your point,
if you look at the string
of 40 things seven,
that's what's tough about
a Twitter or a clip.
And that's why going on podcasts is nice.
It's like, look, first of all, I mean,
it was really fun.
I had a really great moment yesterday.
I bookmarked it because I
was just about to go to bed
but there's a piece that I want to buy.
Cause I just like it.
And, and so there's going to be...
- Can you share?
- Yeah, it's like this little ghost.
I actually don't.
It was that quick.
I was like, literally about to go to bed
and so I was like, you know what?
I don't want to forget this.
So I bookmarked it.
My phone's in the other room.
I'll grab it.
But like, it's just like
a ghost that was drawn
and like colored.
And I'm like, this is neat.
And I think it's on Nifty Gateway in a...
- Is it the Trevor
Andrew Gucci ghost maybe?
- It might be, brother.
It might be, actually.
- I got you.
Gary, I'm so deep in this space right now.
I got you, whatever you need.
- I know you are, brother.
And so
I, you know, I'm excited
because I think a lot of people, you know
I'm trying to help people
have a very important combo
which is, there's two
very interesting dynamics.
There's the reason I have this on my wall
and this costs a lot of money
because it's a former employee
of mine and she's trying
to become an artist
and I want to support her.
And so that's exciting for me.
And I'm excited to meet
people and like big shout out
to my friend, Connor, who I met, you know
he's not a huge digital artist yet,
but like I want to support him.
Cause I like him.
Like, and, and there'll
be people, you know
I think my world's going
to look like there's people
I just like, and I'm cheering for them
and I want to support.
Now, I will never tweet,
"This is a great investment you should..."
Because if I don't believe that,
why would I do that to
him, myself or her, myself.
But there's gonna be people
I want to support their art.
Cause I like them.
Then there's going to be
things like the ghost.
I'm not even sure who's
behind it, back to your point.
I think you're probably right,
now that my brain is thinking.
But like, that I just liked.
I just weirdly like
ghosts, like in general
like I used to draw it a lot.
Pac-Man was huge for me as a kid.
So that kind of ghost and I'll do that.
And then there's going to be a ton I do.
I'm a baseball card collector.
I'm a comic book collector.
I'm a toy collector.
By nature, NFTs are
incredibly interesting to me.
The street fighter thing's really cool.
I want to buy Blanca
because I'm undefeated
with Blanca in street
fighter for super Nintendo
but I also didn't buy it right
away because I do think it
and you know, they were
going to go up very quickly
on wax and then I'll buy it
when, when it comes down.
I don't see, I don't see that
as again, as an investment
I'm going to put that on the flip side.
You know, when I look
at Pepe as a first play
in Bitcoin, right?
Truly NFT on Bitcoin, not Ethereum.
As a collector, I'm like,
Ooh, that has a real shot.
But, but what's funny
is when I use my brain,
and my heart, where I
go is to crypto punks
because I'm like, okay,
that's first Ethereum,
but I fuck, I really love these fuckers.
This is Nintendo eight bit.
These really speak to me.
- Yeah.
- You know, Ethereum, you know
obviously there's a lot of
conversations around scalability.
You know, I'm spending
all this time thinking
about myself up wrapping coins
because who the hell knows which
blockchain is going to win.
And so I'm just doing all
this education, right?
But I look at crypto
punks fairly different
than I look at street fighter wax.
Street fighter wax is singular.
I need Blanca because I
need to show my friends
who I beat a thousand times a block
and everybody would get upset
because I figured out
a way to play with him.
That's a personal thing.
Crypto punks is, holy shit.
This thing could really be an investment.
If I'm as right as I
think I am about NFTs,
this project has a real shot.
And those would be things
that over time I'll put
on the record and be like,
this is what I believe in.
So there's a lot of
conversations to be had,
but I appreciate you saying that.
And I'm excited to earn my keep.
I don't come in here.
I'm fascinated by people
that do well somewhere else,
and think that all of a sudden means
that they should be
looking, you know, to me
I'm starting from the
bottom in this community,
and I want to do all the right things.
I also, and I did this in sports cards.
I also remind people, look, there's a part
of me that likes to collect and support.
And there's a part of me
that likes to treat, it is my
you know, you know, I told a lot
of sports car people I'm like,
look, cause they were mad.
They're like, you shouldn't buy and sell.
I'm like, look, I respect that.
But are you really the human that gets to
decide what I can do?
- Right. Right.
You know, like, I don't know
if you're paying attention,
but you know, open sea exists.
Not for collecting.
It's not like a collecting wall.
Like these things exist.
And so, and it's a very
delicate conversation, right?
One of the reasons so many
artists are not going to
be quote unquote starving is
because of a secondary market.
And what is remarkable.
I mean, literally you
could see this as they're
starting to form, getting a
couple little goosebumps here.
You know, the fact that
the artists can continue
to get royalties.
- To the revolution.
- It's a revolution, Roger.
I mean like, my God,
you know, I could super
understand the artists of the
past, who would be super sad.
They would make a painting.
The gallery, they had a deal
on would pay them a certain amount,
and then wake up 11 years later,
and things selling for $11 million.
And they got 8,000.
- Yup.
- I mean, my God, you know
- No matter how
no matter how many open
seat transactions there are
and beyond, it's always
that 10 ish percent
it's going back to the creator.
- I can't get over it.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what else to tell you.
Like, to me, this is the greatest thing.
So yeah.
Anyway, to, to origin story,
like that was who I was
as an entrepreneur, I
did really well invested
in a lot of companies, built
a large marketing company,
had built a big content platform.
I, this is the scariest of them all.
I'm asking myself questions
of like, "Oh, is this it?"
Like is this gonna be the
one, was this all built?
You know, for example, you
I know you pay attention
to everything, you go.
My, my team is finding all
these videos of me doodling.
I've never shared that part
of me because I've never
wanted to, you know?
- Yeah. I can't, you know, I'm
going to poke around at that.
Like Gary V, Gary V is where it's at.
It just is.
- I can't believe that
something that a lot
of when I've been,
so I posted four or five
of my doodles,
and I can't believe it.
Like I've always thought
of myself far more creative
than I've ever showed the world.
It's actually similar to
when I was the wine guy.
And then I started talking
about business and a
lot of people were like
stay in your lane wine boy,
don't talk about business.
And I was like, my God, I've
always been a businessman.
What's so incredible about minting
and technology and
vectoring and digital art.
I think there's gonna be millions
of people who actually have artistic oomph
who are gonna dabble in a way
that they never thought they could.
And I think that's beautiful.
It's going to be an artistic revolution.
Now I think a lot of people
are gonna misstep it,
because there's gonna
be so much conversation
around finances
when people start seeing Blau,
or Bebo, you know, like they're going to
see things that are
going to confuse people,
just for the community that's listening.
This is what always happens.
There's an art Renaissance
and then comes commerce,
and it gets a little
blurry for a little bit.
And just staying true to
who you are during this time
is imperative.
Because I do think it's going
to be a little bumpy here
for 24 to 36 months as it
settles similar to ICO's.
I think Raj, you know, if
you go back four years ago,
you have the kind of spike,
and then get all these coins, right?
And it took market a little
bit to level out kind of
to where we are now.
I don't think it will take four years.
Cause I think we've learned
from that, at least some people.
- And things are so compressed these days
that, that may be a one
year shakeout period.
- I think that's right.
And I think that it's important
to not get overly emotional
about convincing.
I think, you know, I think
that's where a lot of
people are going to get caught,
the OGs trying to convince.
- Yes.
- I think I say don't
convince, have conviction.
- It's a great, it's a great quote.
So Gary, I have, I have
a bit of a thesis here.
Maybe I'll present it to you.
See what you think.
I think two categories of
artists win and I always,
I hate to be a cold, cold language
like that because here for
the art as well, I kind
of share with you the
trader philosophy as well
as the empathy and just
the love philosophy.
So I appreciate you saying that.
I think two categories win.
I think artists let's
say the top, I don't know
twenty-five loosely that are identified
as blue chip artists.
I think they'll have a
consistent shelf life forever
and ever.
And I think the second category
and what I would encourage
any artist that doesn't know
or gets a bit confused to focus on.
I think the niche artist
who does a great job of,
to your point, having
conviction and focusing
on his or her community,
even if it's small to midsize
I think we'll have that longevity as well.
What do you think about that?
- I think that's right.
I think that's right.
I think,
I think there's a lot
I think both of those play
out exactly to your point.
I think that
I also think it's the
it's the artist that genuinely
cares about their community.
And I think this is an
important thing to talk about.
There are a lot of artists
who don't and that's okay.
I don't judge that.
I just think that to build an economy
around an art, you know,
everyone's like, Oh, this is great.
I, now the artist, don't have to rely
on an agent or the gallery.
What the artist has to
understand when they take
on that responsibility is
just making the art is one
of it's the variable, but
it's only one of them.
I remind people that art is
in the eye of the beholder
there's a subjectiveness that
is incredible around this
and actually cultivating a
community of people that care
about you like matters and
there's a million ways to do it.
You know, Banksy does it different than I.
The reason people care about
me is I engage, you know
like for real, like, you know
and so I think that that
will be interesting.
Who's going to actually truly care
about their early
their early supporters.
You know, I've watched a lot
of artists talk about like being OG
and then even in three weeks
have watched them be less
less about their original community
than the new fancy people
that are talking to them.
- Yeah, you're right.
- You know, that's just real talk.
So like they were razzing
and then three weeks later
they're doing the behavior
of what they were razzing
because now they have the opportunity to.
- Yeah. I think that's
the pitfall right there.
You get too caught up in the mania.
That base, that strong
foundation may not be there
for you when the mania,
when the mania dies down.
- I think the other thing
back to the, you know,
be nice on the way up,
because people catch you on the way down.
I think the other thing people have to
be empathetic to is supply and demand.
Just because you're first
doesn't mean you're best.
Just because you're first doesn't mean you
made something that captures
people's imagination.
And so, you know, just realizing
that this is going to be
a flood gate, you know
one of the great things
of the old world was limited
people got into galleries.
One of the terrible
things of the old world is
that limited people
got into the galleries.
You know, I look
at this like influencer
marketing, actually, you know
everybody can now be an influencer.
And I think everybody now will
have an opportunity to play
out some of their ambitions and art.
You know, the art world
said Jackson Pollock
was not art until they did.
This always happens.
This is history.
So what people have to be prepared
for is actual supply and demand.
There's going to be more supply
over the next six months and NFT projects
than anybody on this call,
listening or watching.
Me and you included can comprehend.
- 100% agree.
- Literally everybody.
And most of it, 98% of it,
is going to be short-term transactions,
which creates a very interesting
and scary bubble scenario.
And so back to convincing
and conviction, the OGs
the people that are really about it,
the people that are here
for, you know, for me
what shook me is like, "Oh fuck,
this is something I want
to be a part of forever."
Just like social media, right?
- You did your, you did your back work
you saw it and now you're here.
- Correct. I spent the fourth
quarter reading and watching.
I even, even the thing that
I most zeroed in on: punks.
I didn't act on which
I wish I did, you know?
- They've come a long way.
- They moved very fast there
before I really got my hands
around some, but I really
wanted to do my homework.
I needed to understand the
ERC 20 versus seven to one
like I needed to, I
needed to be able to go
on a podcast like this
and not seem out of place
or like you're seeing what
certain influencers and artists
I didn't want to do a
project so fast where
you didn't where I didn't know all that.
Like I didn't know about
all the metadata at first.
I needed to understand
for myself what would happen
if a blockchain lost longterm?
Could I wrap the tokens?
Like I don't even know what
the term wrap meant, you know
six months ago, you know,
I knew the macro thesis.
I knew virtual currency was
real for a long, long time.
Hence, I'll be bringing
out those videos to make sure
everyone knows, but you know
I understood a closed ecosystem
of a skin and a video game.
I understood a close
ecosystem of a Madden card.
This brings this now to everything.
And we're, by the way, we're talking
about a very narrow use of
the blockchain and an FTS.
I mean, this is incredible
where this is actually going
from a ledger at scale
to the digital realization of everything.
I mean, we are in
prehistoric days of this.
- Yes.
Gary, I want to play a game.
I know, I know you love questions.
I know you thrive in questions.
And so I do something
called the lightning round.
Wanted to bring it in
a little bit earlier,
and start hitting you
with some rapid fire.
I have some topics and
I have some questions
from the people, you're ready for them?
- Please.
- All right.
The first question, I think
everyone wants to know,
what was the first time
you, you saw the word NFT
the concept NFT.
The very first mention
that captivated you?
- Captivated me or the mention?
- Let's go mention
first, captivated second.
- Mention's a while.
Like I, you know, I, I
remember thinking like
what's fungible, you live like
we're talking to years now.
- Yeah.
- Right.
You know, again, a big shout
out to Aaron Battalion.
Who's an incredible CTO
co-founder of Living Social
which was a group on
competitor back in the day
in 2016, '17 range
in a hotel room in Austin, Texas.
He broke down Ethereum for me.
And I understood, I'm like, Oh, okay.
This is like
in my most basic form, I'm like, okay
Bitcoin is this thing.
Ethereum feels like developers
will build on top of it.
Like I thought API, I thought platform.
It got my brain thinking differently.
And so he, very quickly after that
I already kind of like started hearing
of NFT.
The time it really caught my
attention was probably about
March of last year.
Like something kind of
caught my attention.
I, I was getting big, you know
I was obviously deep in
the sports card world.
COVID hit, and I was scared shitless
to make sure my companies were okay.
And I just needed like
30 minutes, you know
occasionally just to like
learn and be creative.
And that's where I kind of like stumbled
on any maybe, you know, I
don't want to make it up.
So I just kind of like
I definitely knew about the
garbage pail kids wax thing.
- That was one of the
first things I found too.
- Interesting.
Cause that was, you
know, obviously very much
because I was deep into
what's going on, you know,
but that one that was interesting
to me cause I'm like, what's wax
versus a Ethereum, you know,
different block chains.
Punks hit my radar, you know, lightly.
And you know, I'd seen some tweets.
You know, I also knew the
original developers come back.
Like the web 2.0 days.
I knew the names.
When it really caught me was this fall
like September, October,
like crypto punks are
is an important project.
And that led me down NFT, Whoa
this is Whoa, Whoa, this is Whoa, Whoa.
But I was like
in Q4 mode, budgeting,
you know, I'm an operator.
People forget that I'm not
actually quote unquote Gary V,
I'm like running a really big business.
I was trying to set
up still navigating the waters
of COVID losing clients.
What's going on, offices.
And then I was able to use the holidays
like December, January, like
the last week of December
first week of January to dig even deeper.
- The choo choo explosion.
- Yeah. It was like, okay,
this is like, fuck me.
I need to buy some crypto punks.
You know, our blocks. what's
this and like hash mass.
I was like, Ooh, this is what open seat.
I was like, man, this is really happening.
And then I hit
up my homie, Kevin Rose,
former founder, dig.com.
And he's always on it.
And he's like, I'm already in this.
Then we started yapping and
the juices Arab battalion.
Yeah, my brother.
And like just the Whoa,
this is feeling like 15.
You know, this is feeling like 2005, six.
This is feeling like 95.
Oh my God.
This is real, real, real, real.
- What's your first purchase?
My first purchase was a
single crypto punk in January.
Then I bought four hash masks
randomly just to like play.
And then I bought a so rare when Bombay.
So that was my first little burst
of like three or four purchases.
- All right, let's go.
Rapid fire here.
Topics. Number one, New Jersey.
I got to get the shout
out to my wife, Marissa
from New Jersey, seeing you in New Jersey.
What do you think?
New Jersey?
- What do I, what's my word association.
First word association.
The grind
- Love it.
What's the top selling NFT
concept one year from today?
- Crypto punks.
- And that segues us right
into crypto punks word association
- The project.
J ETS
- My escapism.
- Tom Brady.
He pisses me off.
- Dirt.
- Dirt?
- Oh God, you know me well.
I'm honest.
And I want to break that one down.
Cause I have a, I have so much compassion
for who I think listens to this podcast.
So many of you are from the dirt
of NFT and my admiration for
that is at the highest levels.
I think that people
that come from the most
humble places are the people
I admire the most, genuinely.
I believe in the process, like I said
the jets are my escapism.
Cause it's my, my journey
to try to acquire it.
I don't want to, everyone's like
he's obsessed with owning the jets.
They're wrong.
I'm obsessed with trying to buy the jets.
- The process.
The process. I've enjoyed
the last 12 weeks.
Many good things I think will
happen to me in this space.
None of which will ever
compare to these moments.
The first, this is my first podcast
that I'm really talking about it.
The, the, the second I'm like, Oh
I don't have to be scared anymore
if Ethereum doesn't win.
Cause I think this wrap thing
can help learning, right?
The late staying up at
midnight and being like, Hmm
there was a Bitcoin
project pepe before punks.
Like those moments are everything to me.
- Big deal.
- Everything, everything.
I love it.
Like the chats on Twitter,
meeting the people
like having the convos,
putting out a tweet
of last night of like what podcast.
Canceling a pretty
important meeting to do
this with you right now.
Cause I just cause I need it.
You know, I want it.
I love it.
- Let's go the opposite.
Let's go clouds.
- Clouds?
- Clouds.
- When I think about clouds,
I'll think about macro strategy.
I refer to clouds as like, what, why?
So I think macro strategies,
when I think clouds.
- Smurfs.
- And IP, I'd love to.
I grew up on Smurfs.
I like that cartoon.
- Oppose that IP, bring
them into the NFT space.
- Well, that's, you know, it's so funny.
I've talked, there's a trillion.
You know this is the why it's such a,
excuse me, Roger, why?
This is such a huge, huge place for me.
I've been talking about nostalgic IP
at nausea for the last
seven years in my content.
The manifestation of that in this space.
Well, you know what makes me sad?
So many of these incredible things:
Scooby doo, Hanna-Barbera,
Fraggle rock, happy days,
shit that I really love,
like seventies and eighties pop culture.
I know in my soul, 85%,
they're going to go sloppy
into this space and ruin their brand.
Let me rephrase.
Dent their brand instead of exploding it.
Hence why I talk about being thoughtful.
- Yeah. Those who get this right then
the nostalgic brands who get this right
are just going to Jupiter.
- Jupiter.
- Yard sales.
- The thrill of the hunt.
- UFC
- Incredibly underrated sport,
even though it's so hot.
- A hundred percent agree.
The influencer who is not
currently in or exploring NFTs
who you believe should be in NFTs.
- The Rock.
- Nice, good one.
And now Gary, it's the
people's lightning round
farmed out 10 questions, gonna throw them
at you, rapid fire them or
dive into them if you like.
Number one, shout out Zook D.
If the jets win the super bowl
what current artists would you, Gary V,
commission to make a one
of one of the moment?
- Ha, ha, ha.
I would do a humongous search,
and speak to the most
authentic artist that is really
passionate about the jets.
Like can really ask my questions,
and also has an aesthetic style
that I subjectively thought was epic.
- That survey would be so key.
Rooting out who is, who
is the real jets fan?
- I think it would be such a moment.
And if I was like, for
some reason associated
with being able to be the
project that would take a lot
of thoughtfulness, like a micro version
of what I've been doing
for the last six months.
- Number two, shout out Sutton S.
When are you going to
change your profile picture
to a crypto punk?
- When I buy a couple more crypto punks
that I really want, you
know, it's really, it's a
that's just an authentic answer, right?
Like I really want to score
one or two more things.
Cause I'm scared.
I'm also, honestly
it's actually an authentic answer.
It's a 37.
I am petrified to affect the market.
I lived this in sports cards.
- I remember.
- I'm not, I'm very
worried if that happens.
It's funny.
Even this podcast, I'm getting you off.
I don't know how to not
answer the question.
I'm not naive that this is
going to be listened to.
And like, some people are like, Oh
cause I'm being very candorous.
I also don't think I'm always right.
I also think, "Who the fuck am I?"
but I also am aware that some people
which is why I'm like,
"Do your own homework."
I understand I have a nice track record.
I do have a nice track record.
I do believe in my picking ability,
but I picked Yobongo
and thought it was gonna
be the biggest startup
of all time and it failed.
So I think that, I don't
know when I also think
that what I'll probably end up doing
if it's okay with the
crypto punks community
I'll have to probably ask the founders.
I kind of want to like get someone who's
talented enough to make
their own custom version
of me wearing like a green cap, purple cap
or a green cap, you know, like, you know
so I dunno when I'm going to do it
but I do think it will
happen at some point.
- I like that.
TJ shout out TJ.
The real question is, do
you own a crypto cube?
If not, when do you plan to get one?
- I don't, I don't know
when I plan to get one
but I want to get
I want to do more community,
you know, more education on it.
You know what I mean?
Like what I'm doing is
I'm not doing anything.
Like the amount of, I have smart friends
I have people that are being very generous
with their intellect and knowledge.
I just don't rush into things.
- Okay. Smart man.
Shout out new view investor.
Gary, how do you evaluate an NFT?
What is your criteria?
- The underlining information:
supply and demand,
who's behind it,
what do I know about them?
Do I think there are good.
I look, I think of it as
jockeys and horses, you know
the underlining data, the
subjectiveness, and my ability
on the creative part.
That's the horse.
The jockey is, "Who's
the human behind this?"
Do they understand how
to cultivate a community
in perpetuity?
Or are they just trying to
do something for a quick win?
So those are the two big criterias.
- Shut out to wheel.
NFTs with a physical
counterpart, does a physical
de-value the NFT or does it not matter?
- My intuition is that it enhances.
I think it broadens people's intrigue.
I think it's another data
point to make it interesting.
I don't know where the
community sits on this.
If they think that eliminates its purity.
I could see a path to that.
I also don't think anybody
gets to make the rules.
And I think that people that just want to
do the NFT are right
for them and themselves.
And I think the people that want to do
the physical counterpart are
right for them and themselves.
- Yeah. I think that one of
the bigger issues right now
in this space is the physical custody.
No one knows how that's
going to play out, right?
Once the NFT with the
physical counterpart is sold
the physical is distributed.
And then that NFT is re posted
on a secondary sales site.
Do you get the physical, do you not?
What condition is it in, is someone open?
I think that's one of the bigger issues.
I imagine someone's going to step in
and take care of that.
- It's funny for me, my intuition is
that they should be separated immediately.
That the NFT, that's what's amazing
about the blockchain and the ledger.
It's like so incredible.
- It is.
- And I think let the
let the real world do
its real world thing.
You're not going to ever
be able to attach it.
You've already created a vulnerability.
If you think you're going to attach it
because of condition provenance,
like what really happened.
- Right.
- I think it's a nice to
have, it's an added value.
It isn't the thing.
- Right.
- It isn't how my stomach thinks of it.
- Yeah. I think they either
it's either that and
that's probably most cases.
And then I imagine there's
a service that comes
out that does take custody.
And birk tile it.
and it just sits somewhere.
- Exactly.
I think that's right.
- Shout out, Joel Miyazawa.
What is your biggest pain point with NFTs?
- You know, what's so funny?
My brain went you're right away.
It's my knowledge that it's
going to get mucky here.
- Just plays out.
- I know how this plays out.
And I remember the hurt
feelings of people I loved
in web 2.0, when it
started crossing the chasm
of being commercialized.
And the purity of we're going to
change the world, mixing with monies.
And this one is much more
transactional than that was.
- Yes.
- My biggest difficulty is
knowing that there's going to
be a lot of emotion, a lot of money lost.
A lot of short-term thinking,
a lot of bad characters, a lot of people
becoming myth of the overall space
because they'll see somebody
that they grew up with
turn into, in their mind,
somebody who's selling out,
even though that person's
just trying to do something,
you know, that's good for their family.
There's just, there's
going to be emotions.
And I know that.
And so, because I know that
it's like, this is why I'm
I think I'm speaking the
way I am to everybody
which is like, Hey, be prepared.
It's okay.
Like, let go of convincing,
lean into conviction
do it your way.
Cause you'll win in the end.
You will win in the end.
You build a meaningful project
that has real community.
You might get outsold
by somebody who's a better self-promoter.
But let's talk about what
it looks like in nine years.
And that's what I always play for.
- That's the biggest deal
is ignoring the person
who's outselling you
now that, because that's
it's so easy to look at that.
It's just so
- And having the humility
to not impose your way
of seeing this on everybody.
- Yes.
- People, people, you know,
it's like, it's important
because it's what happens
to people that fall
in love with a band that gets big.
They start hating things after.
- That's right.
- But you didn't get to control, you know
you don't get to control
what the band's doing.
You get to control how you enjoy it.
You're in charge of that.
- That's right.
I knew about them first, right?.
It's that, that whole thing.
- Which is going to happen,
which is going to happen a lot right now.
- Yeah. No question.
Shout out to Bill Ellis,
fabulous artist, by the way.
How do we guarantee the
longevity of the NFT space?
- It's been guaranteed.
- Nice, good answer.
Good answer.
Also Bill Ellis.
Okay.
- Let me just triple down in that.
- Yeah.
- It's, you know, Google is
a very big search engine.
I was there when everybody
was fighting it out,
Yahoo Dog pile, you know, ask Jeeves like
all these.
- Ask Jeeves, good reference.
- You know, and a lot of them
were worth a lot of money
on paper and they went to zero,
but search engines are here.
- Yep.
- NFT, collectibles,
arts, and all the music
and all the beautiful
things that are coming.
Will be here for everyone's
rest of their life.
Will there, is there a concern
that all this gold rush
will hurt the brand
to the overall market?
Of course.
Will that not matter in the end?
People thought the internet was a fad.
When the stock market collapsed
in April of 2000, and everyone
dismissed the internet.
That's when I tripled down on the internet
and changed my life, do I
think there'll be a crash
of things that are selling
for a lot of money right now?
I do.
I really do.
But do I think that that
eliminates the market?
No, I do not.
- Yeah. It's inevitable.
But I like your initial,
that initial answer
of it's it's already been guaranteed.
Also, also a question from Bill Ellis.
When are you, Gary V, going
to drink whiskey with me and Roger?
(laughing)
- I'm open to it.
I actually, you know, I'm still through
and through a wine man,
and when my whiskey friends bring it out.
But I am, I am far from scared
of having a good whiskey
or a good bourbon or,
you know, I, and you know
don't forget my family
owns a liquor store.
I've got some stuff, I've got some stuff.
I've got some Pappy, I've got some stuff.
I've got some Japanese stuff.
I've got some stuff.
So I'm in for it.
- Nice.
Shout out Dinette.
Dinette where you bitter 65
Gary in the blou auction?
- I was not.
I saw that.
That was not me.
And I'm so happy for blou.
I really am and talked
to him a bunch before the
process, but I was not.
- Shout out Nicholas Costa
Where do you source your
information in the NFT space?
Who are you following?
- It's funny.
What a great question.
Very I'm just following a lot of voices.
I get into rabbit holes,
speaking a lot to friends
that I really know, like Scott
Belsky, Kevin Rose, Lazaro.
Talk to those kind
of characters
who are a little bit more
outside of it, right?
Then I follow and listen
to you Maddie down in Australia.
- ECL blogger.
- I'm a huge fan, you know, there.
So, you know, there's,
there's, you know, you know
Jeff Holberg, you know
has been somebody I've spent a lot
of time with, you know, trying to think.
Cause I want to make sure Emmanuel who was
at Coca-Cola has been
very involved in so rare.
Matt at larva was very gracious,
and I was able to speak to.
Kevin Rose has been a big
factor, cause he's so truly
authentically a learner too.
And I went through that with him.
He's been big for me and
just continue to add people
to conversations
Donny Overabitzki.
He was very gracious with
several hours of time.
- Picking out some heat right now.
- You know?
So, you know, you know
Beeble was very gracious and you know
his journey,
and just a lot of people
on DM little tidbits.
I also, I also am a very
interesting learner.
I don't like taking
anybody's points of view.
I like listening to them, you
know, and then kind of looking
at things, you know,
Mike Novogratz, you know
somebody I've spent some
time talking to like a lot of
lot of people, but I'm in this,
I'm a very funny character.
I take everything with a grain
of salt because I'm aware
that people have subconscious,
subconscious agendas.
- It's very true.
- Which I don't blame, you know?
So I try to be thoughtful.
I, I watch what people react to.
You know, I've watched every
time I done the artifact drop.
Like I'd meet people more than experts.
I read, you know, I,
I try to get educated.
- Gary, that's why I love this so much.
I love seeing you dive
into NFTs because I've
seen you dive publicly
into other things before, and
I've seen your process before
and I've seen you get
your hands dirty before.
I see you go out there.
And like when it came time,
right, when that came time
and when the next book,
when the next book came time
I've seen you get out there and
then I've seen you pull back
and go through this process.
That's as old as time, I love
that our paths intersected
in this space and see you do it here.
It's really, it's really
meaningful to me separately.
And I just think that
everyone listening to this
in NFTs should be really
excited that you're doing it.
- I appreciate that.
I like being good for communities
and I know how to do it.
And I think when you have
a big microphone, like I do
which I burned, so there'll be confusion.
- No doubt.
- I'm going to be very
careful with it incredibly.
And I will make micro
missteps because we all do.
But I
but I think when you have a
platform, those get compounded.
So I'm petrified to do so.
And I just really enjoy this
community so much, so much.
And look, I mean, let's
call a spade, a spade.
There is the art combo.
There's a heavy layer of
collectability in this.
A lot of the tokens are very grounded
in video game, sports
card, comic book, culture
something that I feel deeply
comfortable with deeply
you know, I've never
collected art and flipped it.
I've only supported art,
which is awesome actually
because I think that's going to be good
for me in this space, but boy,
do I like buying an athlete?
You know, NBA top shop.
Yes. I think it was an incredible project
for a million reasons.
I also think it's an
incredibly interesting project
because I think a lot of
people can lose a lot of money.
Not because Top Shop's
doing anything wrong.
Rojam's incredibly thoughtful.
Flo. I think it's amazing.
It's that those are
more like sports cards.
There'll be the next one in the
next year and the next year.
And I know what Kevin
Garnett and Chris Paul
and Tim Duncan and Patrick
Ewing rookie cards go for
there's not a sustainability
to top shots long-term.
And so I'm very concerned
of how big that crash will be
on it, especially because it's
by far the biggest project
for the normal consumer.
Does that hurt?
Quote unquote the space.
It may.
- Yeah.
- This is why we have to
educate and say things
like this, I'm a macro
Mazer fan of top shop.
I think it's so cool.
Basketball. The best culture.
- Yeah.
- But I'm also monster famous sports cards
but I'm out there saying all the time that
if you buy rookies and not
LeBron and Jordan, you're a gun
somebody is going to be held with the bag.
- You're going to get hurt.
Look at the junk waxer, right.
What's happening right now
in top shots, right now.
Now they're starting to
say anyone who reserves,
will get it.
Well, that's a supply faucet
that's been turned on.
- But even if you go to the original stuff
Terry Rozier can't
maintain longterm value.
- Right. Right.
- Tyler Herro can't.
They have to become a top
25 player of all time.
And I'm, I think Terry Rozier,
I bring up Herro and Rozier
those guys that I admire tremendously
who, at this point,
I'm pretty convinced
are not going to be one
of the 25 to 50 best players of all time.
And I tell people to go look
at Vince Carter or Dirk
Nowitzki rookie cards
and then look at current player
rookie cards who are
four times more expensive
on supplying to maintenance.
And I say, put that into top shot.
You need to be careful.
Don't forget.
There's a bunch of Ethereum and
Bitcoin trillionaires, right
who are diversifying, which
creates economic dynamics.
So it's just a time to be thoughtful
and a time to focus on your conviction.
I'm excited to be a part of it.
I thank you for your, your time.
- Man. Gary, it's been an
absolute, absolute pleasure today.
Let's let's grab that glass
of whiskey with Bill Ellis sometime.
- Send me a DM, let's do that.
- I will, absolutely.
- All right, love you.
I'll talk to you soon, bye bye.
YouTube watcher, what's up.
It's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you
please subscribe because my
commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to
explode stories, polls,
more content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.